así que tal vez se pasó tal vez no sepas
que cualquier ecuación lineal puede
escribirse en la forma de igual a mx + b
donde m es la pendiente de la línea la
misma pendiente de que hemos estado
hablando en los últimos vídeos no que es
el cambio en y entre el cambio lake en x
y b es la intersección con el eje y
también se le conoce como ordenada al
origen ok
así que la forma en que verificamos esto
último es si sus sustituimos con x igual
a 0
si x es igual a cero eso significa que
estamos justo en el eje y si x es igual
a cero entonces tenemos que es igual a m
por 0 + más b m por 0 es simplemente
cero no importando que sea m y entonces
nos queda que ya es igual a b a b así
que el punto 0 b está en esa línea así
que 0 b esta línea va a interceptar al
eje y en el punto b y eso vamos a
seguirlo checando en los siguientes
vídeos ahora para verificar que es
realmente la pendiente vamos a intentar
con otros números así que ya sabemos que
este punto está en la línea ahora vamos
a ver qué pasa si x es igual a 1 ok lo
que obtenemos es igual a m por 1
que es m b y ahora ya sabemos entonces
que el punto 1 m b está en la línea ok
entonces este simplemente es el valor de
ella
cuál es la pendiente entre estos dos
puntos bueno si tomamos el punto final
como este el el 1 como m más b entonces
tendremos la aie final - ya inicial que
en este caso sería b sobre el cambio en
x que es 1
menos -0 que es el del punto inicial muy
bien
este es nuestro cambio y sobre el cambio
en x y estamos usando dos puntos el 1,3
el punto final el 0 como ves el punto
inicial entonces esto simplemente nos
queda m entre 1 que es m así que espero
que esto ya satisfaga tú tu interés ya
digo a lo mejor de estas variables están
un poquito abstractas pero
definitivamente esto es más claro ahora
lo que queremos hacer en este ejercicio
es mirar estas gráficas y usarlas usar
todo lo que ya conocemos sobre estas
gráficas para determinar cuál es la
ecuación de las líneas ok entonces vamos
a empezar con esta línea primero cuál es
la pendiente de a
cuál es la pendiente de a
bueno a ver vamos a empezar en algún
punto arbitrario aunque digamos este ok
y entonces que queremos encontrar
números enteros así que déjenme moverme
tres unidades a la derecha
así que nuestra delta x va a ser 3
y cuál va a ser nuestro cambio en
nuestro delta y bueno es bajamos dos
unidades 2 cuadritos entonces como
bajamos es menos 2 así que para el
cambio en yes sobre el cambio en x que
es la pendiente nuestro camión x estrés
y arriba nos queda menos 2 que es el
camión así que nuestra pendiente es
menos dos tercios aunque nos movimos
tres en equis y bajamos dos en y así que
la pendiente es menos dos tercios por
ejemplo si nos moviéramos uno a la
derecha bajaríamos dos tercios ok
entonces ya tenemos la mitad de este
problema que ésta es nuestra m
ahora vamos a ver cuál es la
intersección con el eje y la ordenada al
origen bueno donde se intersecta ya
habíamos dicho que la pendiente es dos
tercios no entonces y desde este punto
me muevo uno a la derecha estoy bajando
dos tercios baja así que lo que me resta
es un tercio este punto por lo tanto es
el 11 un tercio o bien cuatro tercios ok
es un poquito más que uno así que ve es
igual a cuatro tercios y ya sabemos que
la ecuación es igual a mx más b en este
caso m es menos dos tercios que
multiplica x más b que es cuatro tercios
esa es la ecuación vamos a hacer la
ecuación b espero que ya no tengamos que
estar tantas fracciones en este caso así
que vamos a tratar de ver cuál es la
pendiente primero vamos a tomar un punto
razonable digamos éste
déjenme hacerlo por acá abajo la
ecuación be ok bueno nuestra delta x va
a ser igual a déjenme escribirlo así del
t x es igual a si nos movemos a uno a la
derecha que entonces y delta x es igual
a 1 subimos tres unidades verdad en en
la dirección y así que nuestra del
taller en nuestro camión lleva a ser
tres
así que así que cuando nos movemos una
unidad a la derecha tenemos que nuestro
camión y el estrés así que la pendiente
simplemente queda como 3 ahora cuál es
la intersección con el eje y bueno pues
simplemente se intersectan en de igual a
1 así que va a ser igual a 1 y este fue
bastante más fácil finalmente lleva a
ser igual a 3 x + 1 vamos a hacer ahora
está esta otra línea la línea c
muy bien la línea c primero vamos a
hacer ahora la intersección con el eje y
así que inmediatamente vemos que se
intersectan en menos dos así que ve es
igual a menos dos ahora cuál es la
pendiente bueno el cambio en entre d el
cambio en x vamos vamos a empezar aquí
digamos en la intersección si nos
movemos 2 bueno vamos a movernos 4 a la
derecha para que vean un poquito más
interesante esto entonces cuál fue
nuestro cambio en y tenemos que subimos
2 unidades
entonces el cambio simplemente fue 2 y
el camión x fue 4 entonces 2 entre 4 es
lo mismo que un medio así que finalmente
la ecuación es m que es medio por x
menos 2 que es nuestra ve y ya acabamos
ahora vamos a hacerlo en otro sentido
ahora tenemos las ecuaciones de las
líneas y queremos
esto está en su forma mx + b dependiente
con ordenada al origen ahora vamos a
hacer la figura
con esta primera cuando x es igual a
cero tenemos que es igual a 5 es decir
nuestra ordenada al origen es 5 y está
por aquí así que aquí está nuestra
intersección y la pendiente es 2
eso quiere decir que cuando me muevo 1
en la dirección x me muevo 2 hacia
arriba en la dirección así que me muevo
1 y subo 2 me muevo 1 a la derecha
subo 2 o bien también si me voy uno
atrás bajo 2
si me muevo otro atrás bajo 2 ok y sigo
haciendo eso verdad así que esta línea
se va a ver algo como de este estilo
este es mi mejor intento o que hice si
se seguirá de esta forma hacia abajo esa
es nuestra primera línea puedo seguir
haciendo eso hacia abajo tanto como
quiera así que vamos a la segunda línea
aquí es menos 2 menos 0.2 x más 7 que
igual a menos 0.2 x más 7 así que
siempre es más fácil pensarlo como
fracciones 0.2 es lo mismo que menos un
quinto verdad por x + 7 así que sabemos
que la intersección es 7
la intersección con el eje y aquí está
la intersección cuando x es igual a cero
y esto nos dice que por cada cinco
unidades que nos movemos a la derecha
subimos perdón bajamos una unidad de
inyecte así que lo podemos ver como
menos 1 entre 5 verdad esto es del
taller sobre delta x y por cada 5 que
nos movemos a la derecha nos movemos 1
hacia abajo así que por ejemplo aquí van
5 y bajamos 1 ahora 1 2 3 4 5 a la
derecha bajo 1 o bien si nos vamos hacia
atrás es decir si si tenemos que nuestro
cambio en x es menos 5 entonces nuestro
también lleva a ser uno de estas
fracciones son equivalentes verdad nos
vamos a 1 2 3 4 5 y subimos 1 vamos para
atrás 1 2 3 4 5 subimos 1
así que la línea se va a ver más o menos
así sólo tengo que conectar los puntos
aunque espero tengas la idea porque no
es la mejor línea que he pintado pero
bueno ahora vamos a hacer este otro de
igual a menos x
y entonces dónde está el término be no
veo ningún término b así que acuerda
dice que es igual a mx más ve aquí donde
está la vez bueno la b es un 0 verdad
podríamos verlo como menos x + 0 así que
cuando x es igual a 0 y es igual a 0 y
por lo tanto nuestra intersección con el
eje y está en el origen
ahora la pendiente otra vez tenemos que
verlo como menos 1 por equis verdad
entonces la pendiente es negativo y es 1
así que cuando nos movemos uno a la
derecha bajamos 1 y nos movemos uno a la
derecha bajamos 1 en ok o bien si nos
vamos a la izquierda subimos 1 en jr
ok deben tener signos distintos este si
nos movemos a la derecha baja si nos
movemos a la izquierda sube que más o
menos puedes imaginar está esta línea
dividiendo a los cuadrantes ahora vamos
a hacer el último vamos a hacer este de
aquí y es igual a 3.75 así que aquí lo
que estamos viendo bueno aquí es igual a
mx + b pero no vemos el término en x se
ha ido ha desaparecido bueno en realidad
es que esto lo podemos reescribir como 0
por x + 3.75 ok ahora esto tiene sentido
la pendiente es 0 no importa cuánto nos
cambiemos en x lleno cambia así que de
del talle entre delta x es igual a cero
no importa cuánto nos movemos en la
dirección x nuestra intersección con el
eje i es 3.75 que está como más o menos
por aquí ok
como al cambiar x lleno cambia entonces
siempre va a ser 3.75 es decir es una
línea horizontal al eje al eje x ok y es
igual a 3.75 espero les haya sido útil
esto